業についての話なんですね
えーと まあ業といえば
まあ大体まあまあ聞き慣れている言葉でございます
一応よく聞かれているのは業が悪いという言葉なんですね
それで少々あの 日本の業に対する考え方と
ブッダの業に対する考え方というのは二つあるんだよと理解した方がいいんじゃないかなと
この二つを合わせないで
別々に独立させて それぞれ尊厳を与えて考えた方がいいんですね
これものすごく誤解するのは
私は理解するために日本の考え方を比較するんだけど
それでまあものすごく批判しましたと
バカにしたんだとかね
で 誤解するんです そういうわけじゃなくて
まあどちらの思考を信仰したっても
それは私は知ったことではありませんし
何をしたって私は気にしませんし
人っていうのは自由ですからね
ですから 質問するならば
何々について語りなさいと言ったら
私は釈尊が仏教の世界では
初期仏教の世界ではどういう思考かというだけで
それはたまたま自分の固定概念に合わなかったといって
私はどうすればいいんですかね
その場合は 申し訳ないんですが
もうあれがもう取り消しますということですかね
そういうことはできませんよ
知識世界では あるものをありのままに単刀直入に言うだけのことなんですね
ですから 聞く方々もそれなりのインテリ的な態度で聞かないと
突然ぐるぐると感情が変わると困るんです
そういうわけで この業について日本の文化ではある考え方があります
それは私は知ってます
インド文化でもそれなりの業の思考っていうのはあるんです
それで じゃあその同じ思考に対してお釈迦様が何を教えているんでしょうかということなんですね
それは我々の理解できるかないか
それは別な話で それから納得いくかないか
また別な話で それは信じるかないか
また別な話 それはそれはすべて個人的な問題で
納得いくいかないかということ
その個人のことで まあ私は否定しますよと言ったら
それはそれで一向に構いません
それは個人なこと 個人のことで
それで私は安全のためにこの比較するときは
できるだけ外国の諸外国の
特にヨーロッパとかアメリカとかね
そういうところの例を出したりしてきたんですけど
それで日本の方々 私に言ったのは
そんなこと言ったっても
日本人には一向に興味ないんだと
日本のことから例を出さないと
だからはっきり言われたんですよ
イスラエルとパレスチナの問題を例に出すんじゃなくて
鈴木宗男とかね 田中眞紀子とか
そういう人のことを言った方がみんなよく理解しているんだと
でもそういうことを言ったら
逆に私に何を言うんでしょうかね
ということでもう大変難しいんですよ
もう喋るのは そういうことで
一応例は出すためも それは個人攻撃でも個人を批判することでもなく
ここら辺は違いますよというふうな
この比較という comparative ということがもう学問の世界ではやってるんです
だから 現代学者が私に攻撃するんですね
まるっきり comparative studies ということはしないで
ある人が社外学やってる自分の大学の教授がいて
まあまあこういう風に言うんだけど
私は初めて聞いたんです
社外学 だから勘違いもいいところなんですけど
それ私にとっては言えない
私はそれすごい謙虚に申し訳ないんですけど
私は初めて聞いた言葉ですと
この社外学っていうのは
まあ社っていうのは社会の社で
外っていうのは外ということで
だから社外学というのは犬の学問ですかね
そんな学問日本でありますかね
社外っていうのはもう英語英訳すればアウトオブソサエティでしょ
アウトオブソサエティといえば誰ですかね
学問的に考えてほしい
ホームレスの際もアウトオブソサエティじゃないんですよ
彼らも社会の一員ですよ
ですから ホームレスの方々の人生は何なのか
誰かが研究したっても
それも社外学ではないんです
そんな学問 日本の大学にあるんだったらね
それは私は行ったことはない
そして学者でも何でもないしね
全然学位も何も持ってない
全部捨ててるんです ですから
そういうポイントからあなた言うことはうんぬんって言うと
私も答えたいところはありますけどね
私は一応丁寧にね 社会学ということは聞いたことはないんだと
ですから 私は聞いたことも知ったこともない学問の大先生が
あの まあ質問 こういう質問
南無という言葉の意味はなんですかと
あなた方はどういうふうに理解しているんですかと
それはしつつれに聞いていたんです
それで私は南無っていうのは
サンスクリット語でこういう言葉で
パーリ語でこういう言葉で
普通にはこういう意味で
その世界の人間はこういうこういう意味で使ってますよと
まあ最低日常挨拶としても使いますよと
例えばヒンディー語でナマステっていうことは
南無という言葉から出ていること
もうちゃんとしたサンスクリット語なんですよ
ナマステということはつなげてナマステという風になるんですね
それはもうこんにちはって意味なんですよ
ということは 相手に礼をする
それで歴史的に私は書いたんですよ
昔は生という言葉を使うのは
目上の人に対して生ということを使うんだよと
昔の話 それはどんどんどんどん時間
時代経ると挨拶にもなってるんだよと
それに怒って いえ それはもう私に従いたまえ
私言うことを聞きなさい
私に報復せよという意味ですよと
この社会学の学者が言ってるんだと
だから私だったらその人の話聞きなさいと言って
もう最後に PS 書いて書いたんで
あなたとね こんなことはもうたまったもんじゃないんだと
あの人はこう言う この人はこう言うと私に持ってきたっても
これはもう返事できるものじゃないんだと
ですから 自分に問題があるんだったら聞いてくださいと
どんな疑問でも どんな反論でも返事しますよと
だってきりがないでしょうに
また誰か何か言ったら
それまた何々さんがこう言いますから
あなたの意見は何ですか？何々さんがこう言いますから
あなたの意見はなんでこの人何者ですかね
人のうんこ運びや ですから
こういうもう人格がないということは本当に困るんです
自分に疑問があったら自分を出す
例えば真っ向から反対していてもいいんですよ
私が反対と 私はニコッと笑って素晴らしい人だと思いますよ
しっかりしているんだと
まあそういうふうに このまあいろいろ余計なことがいっぱい入ってるし
で 返事はできないしね
したらきついし 答えはね
中間はない 無視するか壊すかと
だってバイキンはもういい加減に置いといちゃうと
もうもうもう殺菌効かないでしょうに
だから 剛にせとっても
まずこういう立場が理解してほしい
まあ日本では日本なりの思考がありますし
ブッダはブッダなりの思考が持っている
それがまあ両立して これはこれで
これはこれでと まあ比較してみればそれだけのことで
それからどちら信じるかということは
あくまでも皆様の自由であって
私には押し付ける権利はないんです
そこで私は初期仏教しか
知らないんだから それは強引に教室に言うのは私の仕事です
それで話は終わりと思います
そういうところはよく理解して
話を続けていただいて
続けていただきます それで一般的に日本語で使っている業っていうのは
業が悪いという言葉で使っています
で 業が悪いという場合は
やっぱり運が悪いというね
不幸なことを意味するんですね
例えば あなたの業も大したもんですねと言ったら
もう不幸という意味は日本語で入っています
しかし 仏教の場合は 業っていうのはカンマでカルマで行為という意味なんですね
パーリ語でカンマ サンスクリット語になるとカルマというんですね
で この言葉はインドから広げていって
今英語の辞書にも入ってあって
英語でももうもうくだらない映画を見たっても皆様に聞こえると思いますよ
もうもうカルマ カルマと
このまあもう麻薬売ってる人々でもの映画見たっても
まあそういう言葉よく使います
ちょっとイントネーション違うんだから
もしかすると聞き取れないかもしれません
ですから ごく普通の単語になっています
で 業っていうのは行為
行いなんですね ですから
行いは必ずしも悪いという意味じゃないんですね
ですから 仏教の場合は
業といえば良い行いがあって
悪い行いがあるんですね
だからどちらにも業と言うんですよ
ですから もし日本語を初期仏教の人が聞いたら
あなたの業も強いもんですねと聞いたら
この仏教の人はどう理解するかというと
もしかするとこの人はすごい徳の高い
運がすごい強い人かもしれません
あるいは運が悪い人かもしれませんと
どちらでしょうかと ちょっと曖昧になるんですね
ですから 初期仏教の場合は
あなたの悪い業が強いですよとかね
あなたの良い業が強いですよとか
なんとか言ってくれないと
初期仏教側から見ればわからなくなるんですね
だって 業が良いか悪いかはっきりしてほしいと
どちらでも業であると
で 業と言ったっても もうカルマであると
そこで当然ながら文化的にはカルマ
業という言葉を使う場合は
なんかわからないんだけど
悪い方向へ考えがちなんです
これ 日本だけじゃないんです
この業思想あるどこでも
まあ西洋にしたっても
イジスはカルマと言っちゃうと悪いことをさせてるんですよ
不幸させてるんですね
これがもう私にはどうすることもできない
やっぱりまあ人間が自分で考える場合は
もうカルマといえばもう悪いもんやと
いわゆるもう運命が悪いところを不幸なことさせてるんだと思ってるんです
ですから そのその差が間違いは日本だけじゃなくて
どこにでも一般的にはあるんですね
でも お釈迦様の場合は
業といえば良い行為も悪い行為も両方まとめて業になるんですね
行為になるんですね それからまあ
行為といえば行為でいいんでしょうし
なんでこれ 特別な宗教用語になったんでしょうかという
まあこういえば 英語で言えばもう ACTIVITY あるいは ACTION ということでしょうね
別に業やらカルマやらね
言う必要はないんですけど
そこでこの宗教の世界に入ると
なんで業という言葉をわざと使い
カルマということをわざと使うかというと
この結果気になるんですね
行為の結果 気になるんですね
ですから 行為そのものよりも結果とともに気になって喋る場合は業というんです
例えば人が歩いているというと
それ行為なんですよ 人が歩いている
それは行為なんですね
それに業とは言わないんですよ
なぜかというと 歩いたって別にもうどうったことはない
結果は気にしない あの人が座っている
業とは思わないんですね
行為 別に座ってたってもどうったことはないんだから
それでこう考えてください
あの人は観音様の観音像の上に座っていると
どうなんですかね あるいはあのおばさんがとげぬくお地蔵さんの上に座って腰掛けてるんだと
巣鴨にある そうするとちょっと気になるでしょ？何が気になるんですかね
あのおばさんに罰でも当たるんじゃないかなとかね
そんな失礼なことをしたらとかね
その場合は結果気になるんですよ
まあ我々だったら そんなことしたら失礼で罰が当たるんではないかとかね
日本の方々見たら あのおばさんの体
全身の病気はそれで全部治してくれるでしょうとかね
もうなんとか結果考えちゃうんですね
それで結果気になる場合は
業 カルマと呼ぶんですよ
結果気に入らない あの人
あのベンチで座ってますよとか
あの人 ベンチに座ってあちらへ子供はもうブランコで遊んでいるんだよと
その場合はもう業ということは言わない
ですから まあなぜ業と言うんでしょうかというと
やっぱり行為の結果もまとめて考えて
言うんだから業と言うんですね
ですから 業はもう 2つ入ってますよ
行為と行為の結果 だからカルマと言うんですね
そこで業論とかね 業について語る場合は
私たちは何を語ってますかというと
もう結果気になる 結果気になる
どういう結果になるんでしょうかとか
そこら辺はものすごく語るんですね
どんな宗教でも ですから
カルマといえば行為のみではなくて
結果も気になる行為のことをカルマであります
故にカルマについて喋る場合は
どんな結果になるんでしょうか
どんな結果になるんでしょうかという
まあ結果はすごく気になる
それぐらいのことでしょうね
業について語る場合は
で まあそれで世の中でいろいろこういうことをしたらこうなりますよとかね
まあ例えば 善悪をしなかったら
もう家庭は不幸になりますよとか
まあなんとかとかも言ったりする
まあその場合はもう結果が気になって
家庭不幸になって 欲しくないんだから
ではしょうがないということで
戦息をするとかね まあお墓にも何かお水とかね
まあもうなんとかお供えをして帰るとかね
まあそういうふうに何かこの結果が気になる
そこで世界では大体ちょっとしたこの科学では理解できない
まあ神秘的なんですね
ミスティックといえばミスティックですから
もう神秘的というか 科学的には理解できない
この因果関係 業の性にするんですね
例えば どこへ行っても何かトラブルを起こしちゃうとかね
仕事はあっちこっちあっちこっち変える人がいるとしましょう
その人はどんなどこに仕事したっていても
もう 2 3週間でもう喧嘩して仕事を辞めると
それで別なところで仕事を見つけてやるのはやるんだけど
また 2 3週間でもう喧嘩して辞めちゃうと
そうすると これは科学的に分析するよりも
我々はすごく気楽に あの人の業が悪いんだと
と簡単に言っちゃうんですね
で それでもわけもわからなく
家の人々はいつでも病気になっちゃうとかね
一人が病気になっても
やっと治ってくれると
もう次の人がまた病気に倒れちゃうとかね
そういうケースもある
それで誰かと結婚して
結婚失敗しましたと それでまた他の人と結婚しましたと
これまたものすごい 前よりもひどいんだと
それでまた離婚すると
離婚して間もないうち
またもう 3番目にも結婚すると
3番目結婚したら これまたうまくいかない
それでまた別れると そうすると
まあもしかすると私はこういう業ではないかと
と言っちゃうんですよ
だから業という言葉はそういうところでよく使う言葉になっているんです
カルマという言葉は ということは
この科学的に論理的に理解しないというか
理解できないというか
説明つかないというか
そこら辺にだけ業っていうのは世界で使ってます
今は説明するところが
俗世間の業であって ブッダの業ではありません
そこら辺から皆様の思考をちょっと変えてほしいんです
これが我々どなたでも知っている業の師匠
カルマの師匠 ではブッダも同じことを言っているんでしょうかと
で ブッダにしてみれば
もう仏教はすべてすごい客観的に真理
事実だけを語るというふうになってます
で 証拠なく大体は喋れません
お釈迦様は喋ってないんです
そこで証拠と言ったっても
これは仏教はもう知恵で見たことを発見したことを語るんだから
我々俗人にはもう納得いかないものも言ってはいるんです
でもその場合 お釈迦様が私が知ってるんだと
私はこういうことを見ているんだと
経験しているんだと と言うんですよ
だから納得いかなくても
悔しいだけで終わるんでしょうがないんですよ
私に見えないんだから違いますよということは言えませんだからね
それでお釈迦様がこのこの超越した知恵で言っていることは
お釈迦様だけではなくて
お釈迦様の弟子たちももう同じことを経験して
同じことをおっしゃっているんですね
ですから お釈迦様には証人たちがいっぱいいるんです
例えば 業のことやら輪廻のことやら
お釈迦様が話しても それをお釈迦様の勝手な考え方ではないかと
神秘的な考え方ではないかととは言えないんですよ
なぜならば 証人たちがいるんです
私も知ってますよ 私も知ってますよと
私も知ってますよと それだけじゃなくて
お釈迦様もあなたも知りたければ
プロセスはこういうプロセスだよと
こういうプロセスで知恵を開花させてみなさい
あなたにも同じ事実見えるはずですよ
というふうに言うんだから
この私たちの知識に ちょっと理解でき
知識で解説解説できないものは
そのままポイと捨てるということは
まあそれは不可能ですよ
研究する方々は この西洋思考の基準で研究するんだから
すべてポイポイと捨てちゃうんです
自分たちの学生の能力なんですけど
その普通の能力で理解できるところだけ仏教やと
まあそれは私は個人的には認めない
それでまあ 行為と結果というならば
大体仏教はどんな行為も結果持ってますよと
結果ないということはちょっと成り立たないと
だから何かが起きたら
その結果として また次に次の現象は他のものを起きてしまうんですよ
例えば 日が昇ったら必ずしも地球の方が明るくなるんですよ
だから日の出という行為がありますよ
で 結果として地面は明るくなると
さらに暖かくなると さらにいろいろことが起きるということがあるんですよ
だからそれも行為と結果なんですね
その場合はもう誰かがやる行為ではありません
ただ 自然に地球が回っているんだから
もう地球にいる我々はもう日の出や太陽が昇っているんだとかいうだけのことで
太陽が昇るわけじゃないんですけど
で 普通の自然法則なんですが
その時でも行為と結果
行為と結果というのは必ずあります
そういうわけで 行為と結果っていうのは切り離すことはできるものではないんです
そこで物理的に見ても
いろいろ法則が成り立つんですよ
いろいろ法則 まあ例えば
まあ太陽が昇ると同時に
同時に一緒に地球が明るくなるんですよ
今はもう６時に太陽が昇ったことで
まあ９時半になるともう明るくなるでしょということはないんですよ
大体同時に 私はガラスを金槌でつぶすと打つと
打つと同時にガラスが割れてしまうんですね
そういう風に この行為と結果が一緒の場合もあります
その場合は一緒 ですから
必ずしも行為と結果は一緒ですかね
必ずしも一緒というわけじゃないんですよ
例えば 私の頭が痛い バファリンを飲む
バファリンを口に入れた瞬間
頭が痛みが消えたということはありますかね
その場合は一緒じゃないんですね
いくらか時間の感覚はあります
例えば調べてみてください
お腹が空きますね そうするとお腹が空いている
お腹が空いた状態は嫌だから
満腹状態好きだから 空いてない状態
好きだからね 我々は何か行為をする
ご飯食べるという 何か食べるという
皆様方はもう食べた瞬間で
空腹感が消えると思ってるかもしれませんだけど
それをじーっと調べてみてください
時間経つんですよ 食べた瞬間であっ
満腹感が消えたということじゃないんです
そのお腹にいろいろ物事は入ったんだよということで
胃がチェックして 胃から情報が脳に行って
脳がもう空腹感という感覚を消す
消してもういいと それには時間かかります
ですから ゆっくり食べる人は少ない量を食べて満腹感を得るでしょう
ものすごい勢いで食べる人は
もうすごいたくさん食べられちゃうんですね
だから時間かかるんだから
信号が脳から来るまではね
その間でたくさん食べられちゃうんです
そういうわけで まあ食べる量が減らしたい人がどうするべきかというと
食べるものをものすごくゆっくり味わって楽しみながら食べると
例えば 朝ご飯にパン 2枚も食べている人がいると 2
枚食べたってもなんかまだ足らないやとと思う人は
パン 1枚の半分 すごくゆっくり味わって食べてみてください
あ もう結構ということになるんですよ
ということは そちらには因果関係で時間を取るんですね
それでリンゴを食べたい人々は
リンゴの商売したい人々はもうリンゴの種とか何とかいう植えるでしょうに
はい 明日リンゴということはないでしょうね
もう原因は作りましたけど
結果はまた後で まあ時間かかります
ですから この物質の世界を見ても
瞬時に結果が出るか  1年目で結果が出るかというのは
まあそのその場によって変わるんです
時々百年後で結果が出る可能性もあります
200年  300年後でなんとかなる可能性もあるでしょうに
だからそれも人がやってはないかもしれませんだけど
アクションとある行いと行為と結果なんです
だからその法則を理解して
まず理解してください
行為には結果がありますと
そこで結果と行為と結果の時間間隔っていうのは
これまたバラバラやと
バラバラと言ったっても不規則ではありません
ちゃんと規則的で結果が出ます
だから行為に結果は 1 分間で起こりますよというふうな定説は作れません
行為と結果の時間間隔は 1 秒や 1 分や 1 時間やということはできません
そこはバラバラであって
ですから行為によりなんですね
結果も ある場合は 例えば誰か私の手を針で刺したならば
痛みは瞬間で現れる 誰かが私の筋肉が痛いんだから
何か じゃあもう何か貼る
もう何とかありますね
そういうものを貼ってあげますよと言って貼ってくれても
貼った瞬間で痛みが飛び消えてしまうというのはあり得ないんですね
本当は一力湯貼っていたってまだまだ痛いということで
ということにもなりますし
ですから この行為と結果の間で
そうやってこのあらゆる時間設定があって
それは行為によりますし
結果によると行為によりますね
それでもう一つ覚えてほしいことがあるんですよ
この時間間隔を計算するときは
確実にその行為の結果というよりも
観察する人の期待の結果なんです
それわかりますか？例えば日の出と結果
明るくなるだろうという結果を期待する人にとっては
太陽が昇る以前から明るくなっていますね
そろそろ昇るであろうというところで
もう明るいんですよ そこですごく暖かくなってほしいと
暖かいという結果を期待する人はどれぐらい時間かかりますか？日の出と同時に
無理ですね その場合はまあ9時ぐらいになるまで待たなくちゃいけない
3時間ぐらいでも ですから
ある人が結果として暖かい環境に決める
ある人は明るくなってほしいと
私の期待する結果は明るさ
2番目の人は 私は期待する結果は温かさと
というと 温かいということは
結果にする人にとっては 3時間も時間経過が必要なんです
明るくなってほしいという人にとっては
瞬間でその結果が出ています
ですから 行為と結果の感覚というのは
私からこの観察する人がどんな結果を期待しているかということ
そこまでこの物質的な
まあ業の話ですよ だから物質的な場合は業とは言わないんで
これは仏教の場合は因果法則の話なんですね
ですから なんでかというと
やっぱり物質の場合は生命の行為ということは考えているんです
生命の行為の場合は業という
まあそこら辺で生命でもあって
物質の働きでも全部まとめて考えると
仏教は因果法則という
そこで因果法則を語ったのはブッダのみ
他の人は語ってないんです
他の宗教でないんです
そう言っても怒られるかもしれませんだけど
この因果法則しか真理がないんですよ
ですから 真理を語ろうと踏ん張っている誰でも
何か偏見的な因果を言っているんです
でもそれは本物の科学的な因果法則ではないんです
偏見的な因果 ですから
だって他の宗教でも他の哲学者の因果法則を語っているんではないかと
皆様はちょっと考えるかもしれません
もう確かに何か因果法則
まがいというかみたいなものを言ってますけど
本物の因果法則ではない
本当に因果法則 これやと因果法則のみ出して喋ったのはお釈迦様です
例えば なんで人間苦労しているんでしょうかといえば
西洋の場合はもう神を裏切ったんだからという話があるでしょ
神様の話は聞かなかったと
それで人間苦労しなくちゃいけないんだそうと
それでも因果法則なんですけど
でもそれが因果法則ですかと
また逆に その方々もこういう原因でこういう結果だよと言いたいんですね
だからその方々も人類の生き方を見ると
みんな苦労しているんですよ
これ何なのかと それで自分たちの主観的な信仰がありますね
大慈悲の神様が我々にはものすごく恵まれる
もういろいろな恵みを与えてくれ
救ったんだよと それなのに何でしょうかね
我々苦しんでいるのは
というところで ではこういうことにしましょうと
神を裏切ったのではないかと
それで神様が腹が立っているのではないかと
ということで 一応因果法則なんですけど
それはそれなりに立派な因果法則ということを
まあ仏教という宗教から見れば
正しくは見えません だから仏教があるんだからね
そちらの考え方が正しければ
それを信仰すればいいんだからね
仏教はそれを信仰してないんだから
正しくないということは決まっているんです
そういうわけで 因果法則を語っているのはブッダのみ
ブッダがそれをすごい科学的な感じで
そんなにみんなにわかるところまで言ってないんですけど
必要なところしか言ってないんですけど
それもすごい理解難しいし
ですから もうものすごい厳密に勉強している
まあまあ 人々だったらいくらか知ってるでしょうと思いますけど
かなり難しいですね まあとにかく世間にある一般的な
行為と結果の話は因果法則
それで我々生命体としてやっていることには業というんですね
ですから 私たちの場合も
それは 2つとも機能しています
例えばよく運動すると
そうすると健康状態はよろしいと
それは因果法則 まあ法則
それで人を恨むと それでみんなに嫌われると
それが業にするんです
だからどちらが違うんですかね
まあ一応体使いましょう
頑張りましょう 働きましょうという運動しましょうということは
ごく普通な自然法則と似ている行為なんですよ
それでまあ健康的になりました
体の調子は良くなったよと
例えばお腹がちょっと調子が悪いと
それで胃薬飲んで飲むと
あ 胃の調子が良くなりましたよと言えば
そこは因果法則で そこで人のことを憎んで憎んで
恨んで恨んで生活している
それでどんどん胃の調子が悪くなって
胃かゆになって それで胃薬飲んでも飲んでも治らないと
その場合は業というんです
なぜならば 胃が壊れているのは
その人が相手に誰かのことを憎しんだり
嫉妬したり 長い間それをやっているんだからなんです
それもひいて言えば因果法則なんですけど
その場合はわざと業という言葉を使ってます
そんな差がないんですよ
そんな区別いい加減 まあいい加減でいい加減ですけどね
まあとにかく個人の行為という場合は
業と呼ぶんです 自然的な
行為のことを考えると
因果法則ということで十分です
それでインドではヒンドゥー教でもブラマン教でもジャイナ教という教がありまして
何かこの間 根室さんからジャイナ教と言ったっても
日本人はわからないと
確かにわからないと思いますけど
日本人はあまり研究しないまま
ジャイナという宗教があるんですよ
それは私はできれば何とかテキストを探して読むに
あと日本語テキストもあります
あの ジャイナ教って何なのかと
ジャイナ教はやっぱり例に出さないと
当時の仏教はちょっと語りにくいんです
で 結構仏教には影響あるんです
影響というのは 2つありますから
そちらからそのまま影響を受けることも
そちらに反発してこちら何か違うことをするのも影響だからね
ですから この業 業を語る場合は
やっぱり裏にジャイナ教とブラマン人の業っていうのは一応裏にあるんですね
仏教はそれに結局反発的に語っているんです
決してこの あの パクってるわけじゃないんです
研究する方々は お釈迦様は全部人の考え方をパクってるんだよと思ってるんですけど
で それがもう研究だからね
私は知りませんし ただ言葉似てるんだからということで言ってると思いますけどね
言葉似てるんだったら全部町のものやという風に
まあそれはまあまあ 私の理屈ではちょっとおかしいと
言葉はみんなのものだから
誰が使ってもいいんですよ
でも内容は意味はね そのその用語っていうのは
そのその思想体系のものであって
ですから カルマという言葉をお釈迦様が使っているんだから
まあそれはインドにあった思考は後後の時代で仏教に入り込みましたよという考え方もあります
それはもう素晴らしい勘違いです
ですから やっぱり学問を与えた方がいいですよ
あまりにも 事実に反したものは一生懸命研究して
研究らしく作り上げるんだから
能力を磨かせるべきですよ
いかに上手に嘘を嘘を言ってやるかという
だからそんなことをやりたくないんだから
私はもうもう 考えるときでも毛が立つほど研究の世界は嫌なんです
昔の友人に会っても気持ち悪くなるんです
まだこういう人々はもう泥遊びやってるんだと
ですから このカルマという場合は
ブッダが人の業論を真に受けたわけではありません
ブッダはすべて科学的に分析する
すべて客観的に分析して説明しています
では 次にどんなポイントでいいかな
これものすごい膨大な今日の話になりますからね
えーと 皆様に興味あるところは
こういうこういうところ興味あるなと知ってるんだったらね
それだけは喋って 大変お互いに理解して終わりますけどね
それは絶対言ってくれないんだからしょうがないんですね
それでこのジャイナ教に戻ります
このジャイナ教の人々はもう厳密に業論主義者なんですよ
だからカルマという言葉でまとめるんだったら
ジャイナ教の方はまとめた方がいいんじゃないかなと
仏教はどんな論かといえば
因果法則論なんですよ
因縁論 ジャイナ教といえば業論になるんですね
それで業も因縁の一部といえば一部ですけどね
だから徹底してあの業を気にするのはジャイナ教なんです
そうなると 業の思想がジャイナ教の方で発展してあって
仏教ではそれほど発展していないのではないかという
なんていいますか 仮説は成り立ちます
向こうのもう本職だから
ジャイナ教の業は 仏教の場合は本職じゃないんだから
仏教は因縁論は本職だからね
だからどちらかと言えないほど
それぞれどちらの経典もなかなかですよ
ジャイナ教の経典を読んでみると
初めから終わりまで業のことはカルマという言葉を使っていないんです
カルマという言葉を使っていない
だから私が間違っているとなんとか言うよりも
ちょっと気をつけて読んでください
まあ業論なんですけど
カルマという言葉を使っていないんです
それはあまり問題ない
皆様アルダマーギリで読みませんだからね
ジャイナ教典はアルダマーギリという言語でできてあって
読めます サンスクリット語であります
全部アルダマーギリの文章があって
下にサンスクリット語で書いてありますから ２
つ言語を勉強しなくても読めるんです
カルマという言葉を使っていないんですけど
全部カルマなんですね
語っているのは そこでジャイナ教の特色っていうのは
行為 アクションという
それがカルマですよ ですから
仏教より厳密に 物理的にジャイナ教で見ていたみたいんですよ
アクションということ
例えば私はね 太陽が昇ると明るくなると
それももう行為と結果ではないかと言ったでしょうに
ジャイナ教はその機能にものすごく徹しているんです
そこで出た結論はこういうことなんですよ
例えば 私が 誰かを殺してやりたいなと怒ったりする
思っただけですけどね
そこで体に何かをする
その人を殺すことはしませんだけど
蹴ったりする それで私は行為を二つしているんです
一つは殺してやりたいと思ったこと
もう一つはもう蹴っちゃったんで
私に その二つ どちらが悪いんですかね
より悪いんですかね ジャイナ教によると
やっぱり蹴った方が悪いと
仏教に聞くと これは厳密に正しくないんです
ちょっとそういうふうに厳密に正しい質問を作るのは難しいんです
仏教によると 殺してやりたいと思ったことが悪いんです
それが重い罪で 蹴ったことは
まあそのなんで蹴ったんでしょうかとききすれば
それぐらいわかりますよと
まあ蹴ったといえばこの野郎ぐらい思ったかもしれませんしね
この野郎と言って蹴っただけで
後で本当に殺してやりたかったなとか思ったかもしれませんし
だからその思考の方が重い罪であるというのは仏教の立場
そこはちゃんと成り立ったんです
行為は３つありますと
体の行為 言葉の行為 思考と
それがジャイナ教でも仏教でも同じなんです
それでジャイナ教の用語を書かないで
仏教の用語だけ書きます
カーヤカмма ワチーカマ
マノーカマ カーヤカマ
体でやる行為 ワチーカマっていうのは言葉でやる
これはしゃべることですよ
マノーカマっていうのは考えること
それでどちらの方が業重いんですかと
まあこれからまた もう私も皆さんは脱線する危険がありますよ
私も脱線しちゃうんだから
どこかというと 業といえば悪いことだけ考えちゃうんですよ
じゃないんです ですから
私も質問するときはどちらの方が罪が重いですかと聞いちゃいますけど
それも私の方も勘違いになるんです
ですから 罪であろうか
善行為であろうか 徳であろうか
どちらでもいいんです
業です で 我々にとってはもう悪い方がなんとなくわかりやすいだけのことでね
そこで人が体で良いことをする
体で悪いことをする あるいは言葉で良い言葉をしゃべる
あるいは言葉で悪い言葉をしゃべる
あるいは頭で素晴らしいことを考える
あるいは頭でとんでもない悪いことを考えると
そうやって体と言葉と心で我々は業をしているんです
重いのはどちらですかと
ちょっとそのですね 体でしたことも必ず思いが前提にあるのが習っていることだと思うんですけど
だから体でしたら必ず
さっきはまず死にたい
殺したいっていうふうに思って
次は蹴ったわけですけど
殺したいと思った時と蹴った時は蹴りたいっていう思いがあって蹴ったんだと思うんですけど
そうすると別の思いだったと思うんです
だからその行為だけっていう風にいかないんじゃないかな
うん それはいかないんですよ
いかないんだけど ジャイナ教ではきちんとそれを分けちゃうんです
ですから 仏教も分けてるんです
今の時点では皆さんおっしゃっていることなんですよ
それで行為はいくらかリストアップしてみるんですよ
リストアップするとわかるんです
例えば人のために日本人が外国に行って井戸を掘ってあげる
それ良い行為でしょ もう誰かが泥棒したりする
それは体の行為でしょ
そういう行為はもう体でしかできません
それから 誰かがすごい人間の平和のために
優しく生活するためにいろんなことを喋ったりする
それは口の行為でしょうし
あるいは嘘をついたり
まあ噂をしたりする それも口の行為で
それから一生懸命私は何者やとか
死んだら生まれ変わるんでしょうかとかね
神様がいるかいないかとかね
そうやって考えるだけの行為をする
そうやって行為のリストはリスト作っちゃうとどちらかにどちらかには入ります
その入ったところでこの優先順位を決めちゃうんですね
今の時点では難しいんです
こういうこと単純に言いますけど
この一応難しくなるんだから
あの お釈迦様の周りにいた人々が
体でする行為はとても重いんだと
例えば人殺したり 泥棒やったり
そういう悪いこと 欲しまない行為をしたり
人に迷惑をかけたり これはもうすごい罪だと
そこで喋る場合はもうある人は人は蹴ったり泥棒したりはしませんだけど
嘘は言いたい放題言う
噂は言いたい放題言う
悪口は言いたい放題悪口言うと
その人は口の行為やってるんです
でも泥棒は絶対しません
生命殺したりはしません
その場合はもうジャイナ教によると
やっぱり泥棒したり人を殺したりする人が重い罪を犯していると
口だけ悪い人はそんなに重い罪をしていないんだと
そこで番目に ありったけのくだらんことを考えている
でも喋ろうともしない
そうするとジャイナ教によると
その人は一番罪が少ない
罪の場合は良いことの場合も同じことで
体でやる方が素晴らしい徳があると
徳の方が重いと 口で喋る方が徳の重さがちょっと低いと
頭で考えるだけだったら
大した罪に 大した徳になりませんよと
そこは我々も思ってるんです
考えただけでは大したことにならないと
あんた喋ってるだけでしょ
大したことじゃないんだと
行動しなさいと ということっていうのは
一般的にもある思考なんです
そこら辺なんですね 気をつけてほしいのは
なぜならば そこら辺で仏教は全く違うことを言うんですよ
みんな反対することを言うんです
例えば 私個人で考え 私はいいことをしたいな
人々を助けてあげたいなとか思うだけで
あるいはもうそうすると
あんたくだらんことを考えてるだけではないかと怒られる
それで私はもう考えるだけではなくて
みんなに喋ったりもすると
みんなでいいことをしましょう
いいことをするのはいいことではないかとかね
いいことをするのはいいことだよということは
ちょっと変な言い方なんですけど
とにかくそういうふうに喋ると
それすると あんた喋るだけではないかと
でも考えて黙ってる人よりはマシ
考えて黙ってる人よりはマシですけど
でも喋ってるだけだからね
そこである人は喋るんじゃなくていいことをすると
その場合は その人の行為は前の二人よりもいいと
ヴィッパっていうことになるんですね
そこで順位決めちゃって
体の行為は重くて 言葉の行為はそれより軽くて
頭で考えるだけだったら大したことはない
軽いと そこでお釈迦様がその順位を逆さまにするんです
考えること自体が重い行為だと
罪の場合は重い罪だと
良い行為の場合は重い善行為だと
重い徳だと 言葉は考えることより重さが軽いと
それで体の行為は喋るよりも重さが軽いと
どう見ても言葉が真ん中からはね
逆さまにしても どちらにしたって真ん中になっちゃいますけど
それが仏教の立場なんですね
それで世間で私たちも本当にその考え方と思いますけど
なぜならば 普通はあんた喋るだけではないかということは言うでしょうね
小泉さんも喋るだけでしょう
そんな私は言ってはあかんことなんですけど
そう言っちゃうとよくわかるでしょうに
ですから この世の中 一般的にはそう思ってます
そこは逆さまにすると
これはちょっと違うんじゃないかと
そういうことで ジャイナの人々
それから他の他宗教の人々は
この点で このポイントについて仏教とは結構ぶつかったんです
そんな変なことを言うと
ブッダなんかはもうすぐ潰れますよと
かなり喧嘩する したんですよ
だから 業についてテキスト経典を見ると
そのぶつかり合いの話がもうさんざん出てくるんです
どう見たっても どんな常識で考えたっても
喋るだけよりはちょっと行動した方がいいということになるんだからね
そこでこのジャイナの人々とお釈迦様とのぶつかり合いではなくてね
まあまあ 昔よく話し合いをするんだから
話し合いあった場合は
お釈迦様が自分の立場をちゃんと説明するんですよ
結局は心がなければどちらもできんでしょうにと
行動すればいいと言ったっても
そういう行動をするんだぞという気持ちがなければ
できないでしょうね 例えば人を助けましょう
人を助けましょうと言うよりは
人を助けることはヴィッパですよ
どう見たっても 人が溺れて死にそうになっていて
私はそう立って手をこうやって持って
じゃああんたは助けましょうね
助けましょうね じゃあみんなこの人を助けなくちゃいかんですね
もう溺れて死ぬんだからとか
そんなこと言うよりは飛び込んで助けた方がいいでしょうに
そこでその人は溺れて死んじゃったと
こっちはもう行動してないんだから
でもその場合もお釈迦様の立場は変えません
なぜならば 助けたいという気持ちがなければ飛び込まないでしょうに
それで助けましょう 助けましょうと言っている人の気持ちが弱いんですよ
だから飛び込まないんですよ
そこでさらに気持ちが弱い人は
やっぱりまあ助けるのは当たり前なんですけど
考えて黙っているんですね
人が溺れてるんだ 助けるのは当たり前なんですけど
その人の気持ちはすごく弱いだけなんですよ
だから 気持ちの強弱の問題で
気持ちが強になったら
もう飛び込んで人を助けるんですよ
溺れかかっている人 気持ちがすごく弱の人は
ただ考えるだけで誰かに言うことさえもしません
あのね 人が溺れてるんだけど
あんた助けてくださいぐらいも言わないんですよ
まあこれ助けるのは当たり前で
私の知ったことじゃないとあっち向くんですよ
無関心になるんです 無関心になったとしても
その人は自分が悪人ではないと
それを助けるのは当たり前ということだと私も思っているんだよというだけで
そういうことだから 行為の決まり手は
業の決まり手は行為そのものではありませんと仏教は業論を語っちゃうんです
これすごく まあこうやってもう淡々と発展していくんです
だからこの見すと 私たちの常識から見ても
溺れかかっている人が
まあ助けるのはいいことですねとガチャガチャ喋るよりは
もうそろそろ腹が立っちゃいますからね
それよりは飛び込んで泳げなくたっても助けをしている人が立派でしょうし
でもなぜそのそれが立派かというと
その人の気持ちなんですよ
気持ちの方が強いんです
助けたいと ですから 行為を業にした場合は同じことですけど
行為を行為に業として扱う
扱う場合は強弱の決めて
いわゆる結果ですよ 気になるのは良い結果
すごい結果出す 悪い結果出す
弱い結果出すという 業というのは結果のこと
気になるんだから どちらかというと自分の気持ちになるんですね
ですから 仏教においては一体全体業って何なのかというと
人の気持ちですよ 人の気持ち
簡単です 生命の気持ちですよ
そこでお釈迦様のこういう言葉があります
で キーワードはチェータナですね
チェータナイコール業
まあ仏教ではこの業というのはチェータナ
チェータナっていうのをまあ意志というふうに訳します
意志 まあ気持ちですね
ちょっと漢字書きますか
誰でもいいです 意志って意志ですか
え？チェータナの左側書けば
これですか  うん で このチェータナっていうのは
やっぱりまあ普通で言えば気持ちということで
まあしっかりという言葉で言えば意志という言葉になります
ですから 意志が弱いというふうに普通に言ってるでしょうし
意志が弱い人はまあ大したことはしませんし
意志が強い人はそれなりに行動するし
そこで意志が強い 悪いことでも良いことでもどちらでも当てはまります
悪いことにしても 意志が強い人は悪いことはどんどんやってしまっちゃう
良いことについて意志が強い人は
良いこともどんどんやってしまっちゃう
ですから 意志自体は悪いか良いか決められません
だから業は善と悪に分ける場合はもうまあ意志なんですけど
それだけでも決められません
それにもう一つ付け加えるんです
意志自体が悪いか 意志自体が良いかと
意志自体が悪いんだったら
もう悪い業 悪業で 意志自体がいいものだったら善業になっちゃうんですね
そこで業っていうのは意志であるとお釈迦様はおっしゃってるんです
そこと日本の一般的な世界で考えている業とは結構違うか同じか
これは私知ったことではありませんですが
別別で理解してください
釈尊に釈尊においては
業っていうのは心理学的な大事な現象一つなんです
どんな生命でも 動物でも誰でも心で持っている
この意志 気持ち 行為を起こしたいという気持ち自体が業であると
だからすごい微妙な世界になってしまっちゃうんです
だから私たちに言うと
あんたの業なんとか悪い業ですとか
そういう気軽に言えるもんじゃなくなっちゃうんですね
気軽に このまだ神秘的な意味で
言えるものでなくなっちゃうんですね
そこでまた客観的な 具体的な事実の世界が現れてくるはずなんです
そこでお釈迦様も最初に言ったのはチェータナハン
ビッカウェ カンマンワダミ
比丘たちよ 私はチェータナこそがカンマで業であると言いますよと
はっきりお釈迦様は明言します
明言してから次にこれを言うんです
本当は覚えてほしいのは
私は書いてない名言なんですけど
で 次にチェータイットワ
カンマンカロティ カーエナ
ワーチャエ マナサ チェータイットワ
考えてから意志を だからチェータナっていうのは仏教では動詞なんですよ
日本語の意志は動詞ではありませんだから訳できません
だから意志というよりは思いの方がいいかもしれません
あの考える時ではなくて
もう一つ思いありますね
物思いとかね 想という漢字がありますね
そんな感じでいいかもしれません
ですから 思ってから 思ってからチェータイットは思ってから看板行為
その時の訳は行為をする
なす 思ってから行為をする
カーゲーの体でワーチャイ言葉でマナサ心で
ですから 考えることも行為です
体を動かすことも行為です
喋ることも行為です でも
どちらにしても最初に何か思いがあるんです
その思いに基づいて考えたり喋ったりしたりする
で 我々よくやるでしょ
一人ずっといろんなことを妄想したりするでしょ
1 日中 それで随分時間なくなってしまっちゃうでしょうね
それで忙しい 忙しいけど間に合わないとかね
と言うんだけど 時間ないわけじゃなくて
まあすごく妄想するために時間なくなってしまうんで
そうすると洗濯の時間なくなっちゃうし
もうお風呂の時間もなくなっちゃうし
いろいろ時間なくなってしまっちゃうんです
そこで我々はいろんなことを妄想したり考えたりするときでも
なんでそんなことを考えてるんでしょうか
何かまた思いがあるんですよ
何か思いがあって そういうことを考えちゃうんですね
あの思いが業なんです
結果出すのはそれなんです
それからもう一つのポイントで
仏教はこの行為を逆さまにしたんです
心で考えることは思い
喋ることはそれより重さが少ない
体でやることはさらに重さが少ないと
次のポイントはこういうことなんです
どれぐらい結果出せるかと結果論で見るんです
例えば 私一人で体にできることは何なのかね
私 例えば悪いことにしましょう
業の悪い方が理解しやすいんだから
私 この体でどれぐらい悪いことできますかね
もうできることも知られているでしょう
いくらなんでも そのたくさん
例えば人殺ししたとしたってもね
今のこの年で この体で
まあそんなたくさんできないでしょうに
一人が突然殺したかも
2番目の人に行くと もう自分殺されているかもしれませんし
それで人を殴ったり蹴ったりすると思ったっても
もう知られてるでしょ？どれぐらいできるかっていうことは
ですから 体でできることっていうのは
それほどたくさんはないんです
例えば不倫したりすることは
仏教では体にやっているすごい悪いこと
ですよ でも片っ端から無制限にできるということはないでしょ
経験がある方は知ってるでしょうと思いますけど
これはもう片っ端から無制限に不倫することやらね
できるわけじゃないんですよ
もう知られてるんですね
どれぐらいかという ですから
悪いことだったら悪い結果の重さっていうのはもう決まっている
良いことだったらそれも決まってる
私はこの体で人を助けてあげましょうとかね
したっても 能力は決まってますね
それほどできないということだから
そんなたくさんの量は体ですることはできないんですよ
次に考えてください 言葉のこと
私に私の体では人を殺そうと
悪い方で人を殺そうと思ったっても
せいぜい一人 二人 三人で終わっちゃうんです
もし私は喋って喋って喋って
あの人々は我々の敵やとかね
あなた方の敵だとかね
いろんなことを企んで
あなた方をもう不幸にしようと思っているんだぞとか
そうやって喋って喋って喋って
人の感情を引き起こして暗示でもかけちゃって
マインドコントロールでもしてしまっちゃって
人々を大量殺人に導くことをできるんでしょ
だから言葉でできる悪いことっていうのはかなりですよ
それでこの世の中を見たっても
ほとんど問題 言葉でしょ
良いことにしたって 悪いことにしたっても
まあちょっとした言葉で大変な結果になると
ちょっと口が滑ったところで
英語では舌が滑るというんですけど
日本語で口だってどっちですかね
はい 舌が滑る ちょっと舌が滑っただけでも
もう大変な結果になるんですよ
だから言葉でできる良いことも悪いことも
体でできることよりはすごいたくさんになります
例えば嘘をついていろんな損害を与えることできますよ
噂をしてかなり人々を不幸にすることはできます
その人が自分の体でやってみなさいと言ったら
もうほとんど何もできないと
そういうことだから 言葉でやることがすごく大きいんです
良いことも悪いことも
次に頭で考えること それから人間っていうのはすべて考えてやるんだから
考えなきゃ何もできんですよ
考えなきゃ何もできない
ですから 一切の悪いことのも良いことのも
超犯人というか もう本物の犯人は考え方なんです
私は一人の人を殺そうと思った時に考えてやっているでしょうし
そこで私は体体力はない
でも頭が動く 体の体力でいえば一人の人も殺さないんだけど
頭でカラクリやっちゃうと
頭でいろいろ工夫できるならば
あの 何でしたっけ？団地一つも
焼く焼いてしまうような火事にすることでもできるかもしれませんよ
ですから 人が恐ろしい
人が起こす犯す罪にしても
その人が頭が鋭くなればなるほど怖いんですよ
もうただのすごく頭が悪いバカな人だったら
もう何のそんな危険じゃないんですよ
例えば放火しようと思ってもすぐバレちゃう
頭が悪いんだからすぐ見つかるとかね
そうするとそこら辺に火をつけちゃったんだけど
もう火はもう燃えなかったとかね
頭が悪いんだから もしかするとそこら辺ドラム缶があって
そちらに何かポイと捨てていく
ドラム缶の中だから全然大丈夫とかね
でも頭も鋭いんだったらどうですかね
大変ですよ ですから 頭でする行為
思考の行為が巨大でキリがないんだと
無料ですよ 悪でも善でも
だから人類は破壊になる
人類殲滅になるところまで武器開発とか出てきたのは
これはノーベル賞を個つでも取れるぐらいのすごい鋭い能力ある学者たちなんですよ
研究者たちなんですよ
ものすごく研究して 研究して
もう作る 作る 作ると ですから
この例えばもう今 地面の中でどう穴でも掘って隠れると
空から衛星から見てもわからないでしょ
身を守ることができます
それで武器開発する 新しい新型爆弾はもう地面の上で爆発しないんですね
自分も掘ってじっと下に行くんですよ
行ってそこで爆発する
そうすると地面の中で隠れている人々も死んでしまっちゃう
それから爆破 爆発する力はないんですけど
強烈に熱を出すと そうすると隠れて
じゃあ隠れてみなさいと
熱風がチコチコ もう 300度
400度で熱風がチコチコと
もうみんな死んでしまっちゃう
だからどんどん技術を開発するんです
それで昔だったら目で見て敵だとか発見しますけど
そうすると夜は安全ですよ
今はできません 真っ暗であろうとも
もうちゃんと見える だからそういう技術
私たちにできますかね
私にはできません 皆様もそういう技術は持っているかもしれませんだけど
失礼なこと言えませんだけど
私みたいな人には絶対できません
勉強も何もしていないし
そういうことだから 頭さえ良ければという
ちょっと言いにくいんですけど
頭がかなり動く場合は
かなり活動する場合は
そういう人々に悪いことをさせちゃうと
どこまで悪いことをするかわからなくなっちゃう
同じくいいことをさせちゃうと
どこまでいいことをするかまたわかったもんじゃないという
ということで 思考でできることっていうのはものすごい巨大なんです
ですから お釈迦様はすごく論理的に
業の場合はもう重い 限りなく強いっていうのはあなたの思考そのものですよと
手の足の動きよりも だから悪い方に使うんだったら
まず思考を気をつけろと
いい方に導くんだったら思考を直せと
思考を直せたらもうそれで OK と
万事解決 だから考えてから行動するんだから
だから良い人間になるか悪い人間になるかということはすごい簡単ですよ
良い人間になるために 10 年間も公園の掃除をやっているんだと
それでも良い人間にならない場合がありますよ
毎日掃除しているんだから
昨日 掃除したら今日また汚しているのではないかとかね
その人どんどん怒るかもしれません
そうすると 子供たちがふざけて遊んでると子供と怒鳴ったりするかもしれません
あんた方遊んでもいいんだけど
散らかさないよとかね
そうすると子供たちは怖いおじいさんがいるんだぞと言って逃げたりするし
ですから もう 10 年間
私は毎日毎日公園の掃除しますよ
それで良い人間になってみるぞと言ったっても
ちょっとわからないんですよ
良い人間になるかならないかっていうことは
かえって怖いおじいさんで終わってる終わる可能性もあります
どんどんエスカレートして
この公園散らかす犯人たちを捕まってやろうではないかと
じっと隠れて睨んでいる可能性にもなりますよ
だから その体の行為だけで良い人間になるか悪い人間になるかっていうことはわからない
それでお釈迦様の教えは思考を直してみなさい
思考自体を直してみると
何のことなく良い人間なんです
例えば 私は良いことをしたいんだと
良い思考をしたいんだ
みんな公園で楽しく遊んで
気持ちよく遊んで楽しかったらいいんじゃないかなと
そうするとみんな楽にしてあげるぞと
だったらゴミなんか分別しなくても
それ使いたい 捨てたい放題でいいんじゃないんですかと
みんな気楽だから 弁当食べてそのまま置いたままで帰ると
それで私が次の人にはこれ迷惑だから
全部分別して分けて ちゃんとゴミ箱にしておくと
それで思考を変える そうすると
その人がまた子供たちやら若者が来て
弁当やらいろんなジュースやら空き缶もうあっちこち捨てて遊んでいると
じゃあそろそろ仕事を出そうと楽しいんですよ
みんな元気で遊んでいるんだよと
じゃあ今日も結構仕事があるんだぞということで
では仕事を すごい楽しく仕事をする
そうすると その人は毎日毎日充実感があるではないかと
私にはごちゃごちゃ考えたり悩んだりする暇がないんだと
きちんと時間に起きて
朝起きて早く午後も行って
全部手入れしてきれいにして
すごい清々しい気持ちで戻ると自分の家に
それでそうやって 2つの人間が成り立つのですよ
ただ 行為だけでいいことをしてやろうと思ってやっている人の場合は
良い人間になるかならないかはわかったもんじゃないんですよ
初めからの思考を直して行動すると
どんどんどんどん幸福も広げるし
楽しみも広げるし しっかりした良い人間になってしまうんですね
そういうことだから 良い人間になるのはいとも簡単
この世直しに踏ん張って頑張らなくてもいいんですよ
世界救済してやるぞとかね
自分の思考パターンを変えてみる
それで完璧な良い人間になるんです
で そういうことが これはすごい論理的だと思いますよ
それからすごい心理学的な立場から見ても
ものすごいサイコロジカルと思いますけどね
だから 例えば私が一人で
私が本当にいい人間かな
悪い人間かなとかねと思っている場合は簡単ですよ
私は日々何考えているんですかねとかね
日々何考えてるんで それで決まりますからね
ですから 例えば日々私はもう子供のことを恨んでいるんだとか
だから悪い人間と言ったっても
もしかもうちょっと気持ち見たらね
本当に恨んでるんですかと
恨んでるわけじゃない
性格悪いんだから腹が立ってるだけやとかね
わかるでしょうね そうすると
本当は子供のことをすごい心配はするんですが
子供は言うこと聞かない
もう性格が悪い そういう腹が立ってる
それはうらめやとわかるでしょうに
だから自分の本音というか
本心というかね そこら辺はきれいにしておけば
もう完全な良い人間になるんですね
ですから 完全たる良い人間になる方法というのは
この慈悲の瞑想で教えていることなんですよ
その慈悲の言葉を自分の本心に入れておく
それで気楽に生きてみてください
それから余計な心配しないで
何の焦りもなく自由自在に生きていればいいんです
すべてうまくいくんです
日々充実感が生まれてくる
やることは何でも成功するようになる
そういうことだから 仏教はこの普通
私たちもやっぱり喋るよりはやった方が行動した方がいいんではないかという理屈でいますが
お釈迦様はもう逆さまにしているんです
それは 2つの点 一つは意志がなければ何もできないこと
もう一つは結果の量を見ると
無制限に量が増えるんですよ
考え方になってくると
悪いことも良いことも
言葉にはリミットがあります
言葉にもものすごいできますけど
例えば私が言うことはそんなたくさんの人には聞こえません
もしマスコミの人が何か言ったら
全国にいっぺんに広げるでしょうに
だから私に騙される人々の数よりは
マスコミに騙される人々の数というのはもう決まったもんじゃないんですね
そうやってこの言葉も能力次第
体はもっと強くない 体でできることは
ですから 行為の場合はそういう順番があります
体のことよりも 心で あなた頭の中で何考えているんでしょうか
っていうことは気をつけなさいと
ですから 便利なところもありますよ
例えば自分の舌が滑っちゃって
人が傷ついちゃったと
人が傷ついちゃって でも自分がそんな気持ちなかったならばね
本当は相手のことはまあ好きでしょうし
褒めてあげたいでしょうし
軽視しているわけじゃない
だから相手のことをあまり信頼しすぎちゃって
ちょっともうあまり遠慮しないで何か言ってしまったと
言ってしまったこと その人がすごく傷ついたってもいたっても
それで私は悪い罪を犯すと悪い罪を犯す
そんなに困らなくてもいいんですよ
結果が悪いかもしれませんだけど
自分が別にそんな気持ちなかったんだからね
自分にはそんな悪い罪になってないんですよ
例えば私はまあどこかに座ろうとする
座ろうとしたんですけど
まあ腰が滑っちゃって倒れたんですね
倒れたところでもう猫が寝ていて潰されちゃったと
それでもう腸も全部出ちゃったって
頭ももう頭の骨も折れちゃって
もうそのまま死んだと
食酢やと ああ 悪いことをしましたなってみんな困っちゃうでしょうに
なんて悪いことをしたんですかとかね
そのショックでもう寝られ
寝られなくなるとかね
あれはもう意味がないんだ
私だったらきれさっぱり忘れる
だってそんな気持ちなかったんだから
そんな気持ちはまるっきりなかったでしょ
猫を蹴ろという気持ちもなかったし
たまたまもう腰が滑っちゃって倒れただけのことだからね
それで死んじゃったんですかと言って
それは処理処分するだけで終わっちゃうんです
逆に悲しいんです 悲しいですけど
私にしたっても それは自分が悪いことをしたという悲しみじゃないんですよ
なんで生命っていうのは不幸やと
野良猫はね 家からも捨てられちゃって
食べるものもなく苦労している上で
これで人が倒れる 体の上に落ち込んで落ちてしまって
潰れて死んじゃったと
というふうなことは考えますけど
私のせいやと思わないんですよ
テレビでいろんな不幸な人々のアフガンとかね
出てくると なんで人間っていうのはこんなに不幸でしょうかとかは悲しいんですよ
平和でいられないんですかね
仲良くすればいいんではないかなとかね
でも一つ私のせいだとは思わないんです
悲しいんだけど それは全然この精神的に問題にはならないんです
ある面で言えば 私は関係ないし
行ったことではありませんとと言って手を引くではなくて
自分にもまあこういうところでもやっぱり意見ぐらいでも述べてあげる
それぐらいしかできないんだよと
人間は平和でいた方が正しいと
喧嘩しない方が幸せやと
宗教差別やら人種差別やら色差別やら言語差別やら
そんなものはもうくだらん主観で取っ払いましょうと
我々はこちらそんなことしゃべったって
何一つ我々みんなにできないでしょうに
でもそれぐらいしかできないんだから
まあそれでまあ止まるということなんですね
だからこう思考が問題だから
たまたま考えてもないとき
我々はまあまずいことをやってしまうときありますよ
これは誰の人生にもありますよ
まずいことをしてしまったと
でも全然後悔したり 落ち込んだり
悩んだりする人は必要はないんです
自分の本当の気持ち見てみる
例えば わざと人を騙したくて嘘をついたとしますね
それが悪いんですよ それでふざけて
まあ別に根拠もないものをいい加減なことを言ってしまったところで
みんなそれを本気にとっちゃって
あの人こういうことを言ったか
こういうこと言ったら大変だ
大変だとかね それで勝手に困ればいいんですよ
こっちはそんな気持ちなかったんだからと
そこまであんた方困ってんだったら
今度から言葉に気をつけようと
それぐらいのことで終わっちゃうんですよ
なんで私は無責任なことを言ったんでしょうかとかね
悩む必要ないんですよ
言った時はもう楽しくて
ちょっと調子に乗って言っただけのことだから
ですから 仏教の場合は
いつでも一つ 君の気持ちは何でしたか？と
君はそんなつもりでしたかと
それだけなんですよ だからこの例を出すと残酷に聞こえる時もありますよ
例えば どこかの工場でいろんな化学物質を扱っていると
そこを厳重にもう気をつけて扱っている
そこでいろいろ機械の修理とかいろいろやっているところで
何かもう何かもうカランとかなんとかね
もう丁寧に開けようと思ったところで
そこはちょっともう壊れてしまったと
その人の手で 壊れたところで
すーっとこの毒ガスがもう奥に入っちゃって
そこら辺に住んでいても
大体 ２００人ぐらい死んじゃったとしますね
そこでこの人は 200人殺した殺人鬼やとかね
業務上過失云々とかは
私は別に まあ業務上過失があったらこれは間違いですから
それはもう罪ですけどね
だからなくて まあ時々ネジを回そうとしたらネジが壊れる時もあるでしょうに
それが業務上過失とか言ったってもね
自分がプラスドライバー持ってきて
なんとかこれ外そうとしたっても
それは外れるところがもうネジがぐちゃぐちゃ壊れてしまうと
外せない それでもう大変なことになりましたということ以外でもありますよ
ですから そういう風に
まあ自分は気持ちは全くないところで
200人ぐらい 周りの人々は死んだことになっても
まあ悲しいことですね
人々はもう知らないところですぐ殺されちゃったと
ぐらいで終わっちゃうんですよ
なんて私は 200人も殺しちゃって
殺人鬼でと悩む必要は全くないんです
なぜならば 君の気持ちは何でしたか？と聞けば
私はすごい真剣にこれを開けようとしただけですよと
それでガチンと壊れちゃったんだと
それだけのことだから
で 私は防護服を着ていたんだから大丈夫でしたけど
そういうことですよ それはすごい客観的な真実
事実なんです ある面で
仏教は人が 100人死んだっても
200人死んだっても
1万人死んだっても そんな気にすることもないと言って言いながら
かすかにでも生命に迷惑かけるなよとも言ってるんです
そのそういう立場なんですね
世の中で人を死ぬということは
いつでも事故で死ぬは
自然に死ぬは 病気で死ぬは
一人二人死ぬこともあるし
伝染病なんか出てきたらもう全部みんなもう洗い流しちゃって死ぬ時もあるし
で それでなんうんということでもないんですね
だから気をつけるのは
自分の意思で悪いことをしてはいけませんと
そういうふうに 我々は楽に生きることはいくらかはできますし
楽に人間良い人間になることもできますし
えーと まあそれでまた忘れたポイントがありまして
次に この思考はどれほどすごいかというと
例えば考え方は良い方に育てる
例えば慈悲の瞑想ありますね
私が幸せでありますように
それだけでもすごい心が清らかになるんですよ
すごいわがままな瞑想なのかもしれませんだけど
私が幸せでありますようにと
その一片できている人は他人に迷惑をかけませんだからね
それだけでも それにその人は親しい人々にしたり
それから生きとし生けるものにしたりして
そうすると その人には生命はどれぐらいいるかという
その人の能力次第 慈悲が強くなるんですよ
すごい立派な もう想像を絶する立派な人間になるんです
ある人が人間だけに限るかもしれません
あるいは生きとし生けるものと言った途端
もう東京都の人間だけにするかもしれませんし
あるいは日本だけの人間にするかもしれません
もう一人は地球の全部人間にするかもしれません
もう一人一人はもう動物をみんな入れるかもしれません
もう一人は戦争の存在もすべての生命にするかもしれません
とにかく自分の能力次第
それで我々の能力次第で
慈悲の瞑想からどれぐらい徳を積みますかといえば
答えがないんですよ あなたの能力次第でいくらでも住めますよと
無料ですよと 無制限ですよ
そういうことだから 仏教は思考の方がずいぶん大事に考えるんです
大事なポイントとして
悪い方でもいい方でも思考ですよ
で ポイントは そこで仏教は瞑想ということを推薦しているでしょう
瞑想はすべて思考の管理なんですよ
心が悪い方向で 汚い方向で回転しないように
汚れた方向で回転しないようにあらゆるからくりをする
それが瞑想ということなんです
ですから 善行為の中で最高な善行為
誰でも徳を積みたいと
良い人間でと思っているでしょうに
そうすると最高な善行為は当然ながら瞑想になるんです
ただ黙って座って 自分の思考の管理する
それほど良いことは世の中であり得ません
そこでお釈迦様がすべての真理を発見して
完全に解脱を得て 完全にすべての煩悩をなくしちゃって
世界で初めて完全たる悟りを開いて
あれは 人々に幸福になるために
もういろいろ仏教も教えておいて
それでどんな行為でやったんですか？瞑想でしょ
ですから 一切の苦しみなくして幸福になることも
思考の管理でできます
そういうことで 仏教の世界では儀式儀礼は全然立場がないというか
まあ格がすごいんですよ
まああって悪いというわけじゃないんだけど
まあ重役と脇役もないぐらいですよ
脇役にちょっとお手伝いしなさいとかね
もう台本を貸してあげたり
水をあげたりとかしますね
舞台なんかの場合は この舞台に出る人々もいろいろ準備しなくちゃいけないんだからね
そこで濡れたタオル はい
どうぞとかね それで重役の人々で重役というんですか
メインアクターではなくて
この脇役のやっている人々のお世話係みたいなもんですよ
仏教の世界のこの宗教儀式
儀礼っていうのは まああって悪いわけはあっても悪くはないんです
ぐらいのことで 一番大事な役はもうメインアクターはもう瞑想なんです
それはなぜかというと
これは思考の管理 だから合論からは見てもそういうことになっています
そこでなんで行為に業と言いますかというと
それは結果が気になるんだから
結果が気にならなかったら
行為も気にする必要はないんですよ
なぜならば 例えばなんで野球の場合
ピッチャーがうんぬんとかね
もうすごい投げ方やら足の上げ方やら
もうそんなに気にするんですかね
あのコーチをやっている時は
あなたの足の上げ方や運や運営はとかね
ボールはこういう風に取って取ったらこういう球になるんだ
こういう風に取ったらこういう球になるんだとか
そこまでなんで気にするんですかね
ただ取って投げればいいでしょうに
そうすると結果が悪いんですよ
だから結果気にするんだからすごい気をつける
同じこと 我々の行為も結果が気になる
だから行為に業という結果が気にならない行為には業と言わない
窓 窓まで歩いたとかね
ちょっと座ったとかね
それはただ座っただけで
その言葉だけで十分です
はい こんな結果気にならないんですね
まあ一応一部としてはまあこれぐらいの理解でいいんじゃないかなとは思います
これはこれで業わかったんじゃなくて
これほんの一部なんです
でもほんの一部も 今日は頑張ったのは
この仏教の本心にちゃんとした本物
メインロードにあるものやと
脇道ではないんだと 仏教学者の先生方々は
これは仏教に後からついてきた脇道だよと言ってますけど
我々学者でない単なる坊主で
宗教形から見れば脇道ではありません
仏道そのものの話なんです
ですから どこかの宗教からパクリではうまくいかないんです
同じ言葉を喋ったんだから
まあ同じ言葉に似ているだけのことなんです
それでまあ解脱 涅槃までも言論ですよ
心育てれば育てるほど良い人間になると
だから我々はこんなに
このどうすれば金持ちになるか
どうすれば美しくなるか
どうすれば そういう経典一つあります
次回 来月 そこら辺ちょっと触ってみせますが
それはあんまり危険で言いたくないんですよ
言っちゃうとどんな結果になるかちょっとわからない
皆様の思考から計算すると
この取り方ですね もう包丁はあれ取って取る場合もあるし
この切れるところから取る場合もありますからね
この蛇使いでいつでも尻尾で取ると困りますしね
やっぱり蛇を頭でつかむんだからね
そこら辺ちょっと不安ですからね
すごい私は警戒しますから
この仏教であるんだからで
なんか何でもペラペラ喋ってるような気がするでしょ
えらい気楽にいい加減でいい対応で
そうじゃない ものすごく気をつけるんです
ものすごく気をつけて喋っているんです
あまりも気をつけすぎだから
この日本語をちょっともう丁寧にとか
そこら辺にはもうエネルギーないんですよ
私は宗教 歴史やらあらゆる経典からね
経典の内容やら その経典を勉強したミャンマー人
スリランカ人やら どこで間違っているか
どこで正しいかとか そこら辺
社会学的にも宗教学的にも歴史的にも考えて考えてももう疲れちゃいます
ですから 敬語を使おうとか
そんなもうところじゃないんです
だけどまあ でもかなり気をつけては喋ります
あの 仏教の人々は聞きたがるのは
こういう具体的にどうすればきれいになるかとかね
どんな行為すれば どんな徳を積んだらがんが治りますかとかね
どんな善行為すれば金持ちになるかとか
そう聞くんだから答えありますよ
全部 あるんですけど これはちょっと遠慮します
ですから いくらか来月
そこら辺も話してみます
そういうわけで 業というのは我々の気持ちそのものであると
珍しいものではありませんと
私の幸福は私の気持ちが決めてくれるんだと
という結論で話を終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます